hey this is press tow
Walker problem one if x is greater than
zero and x + 1 /x is equal to 5 then
find the value of the < TK of x + 1 /
the < TK of
X problem
two if x + 1X is equal to the < TK of 3
then find the value of x ^ 100 + 1 / X
to the power of 100 I thank Sonic for
the
suggestion pause the video if you'd like
to give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems so let's solve problem
one we'll get started by taking the
square of the square root of x + 1 / <
TK X if we expand this out we get the
square of rootx + 2 * rootx multiplied 1
/un X plus the sare of 1 /un
X in this middle term this < TK of x *
1/ > X will cancel out to be 1 so the
square otk X is equal to X the second
term becomes two and the square of 1 /
rootx will be equal to 1 /x
so this all is equal to x + 2 +
1X we can now rearrange the terms so
that we have x + 1 /x + 2 but we know
that x + 1X is equal to 5 so we can
substitute in to get 5 + 2 and this is
all equal to
7 so now we know the square of what we
want is equal to 7 and X is greater than
zero so we'll take these positive square
root root so that means < tkx + 1 /un x
is equal to < TK 7 and that's the
answer now let's solve problem two so
there are many ways to solve the problem
I'll just show you one of the
approaches the first thing we might do
is we might Square the first equation so
we the square of X+ 1X is equal to the
square of < tk3 we expand the binomial
to get X + 2x * 1x + 1x^2 is equal to 3
we can then simplify so that we get x^2
+ 2 + 1x^2 is equal to
3 then we have x^2 + 1x^2 is equal to 1
so we've made some progress we'll put
this equation to this side and we'll try
another thing let's take the original
equation and Cube it so we have X Cub +
3x^2 * 1x + 3x * 1x^2 + 1X Cub is equal
to 3 <
tk3 we can now simplify this equation so
we have X Cub + 1X Cub + 3 multiplied by
x + 1 /x and this is all equal to 3 <
tk3 but now we know that x + 1X is equal
to < tk3 so we can substitute in so we
have X Cub + 1 X Cub + 3 < tk3 is equal
to 3 < tk3 and that means that X Cub +
1X Cub is equal to
zero so we're going to put this equation
to the side but let's do another
manipulation on it we'll multiply both
sides of this equation by X cubed so we
end up with x ^ 6 + 1 is equal to 0 and
now that means x ^ 6 is equal to
1 so now we have x^ 6 is equal to1 we
can do some tremendous
simplifications so we have x ^ of 100 we
know that 100 is equal to 6 * 16 + 4 so
x ^ of 100 can be simplified to be x ^
of 6 * 16 + 4 we can then break this
apart into x ^ 6 raised to^ 16 multip by
x ^ 4 so we'll substitute that into our
expression then we know that x ^ of 6 is
equal to -1 so we can substitute in now
-1 to the^ of 16 will be equal to 1 so
this all simplifies to be x ^ 4 + 1/ x ^
4 so how do we figure out that
value we'll just do one more calculation
let's take x^2 + 1x^2 is equal to 1 and
square both sides of the
equation so now we get x ^ 4 + 2 * x^2 *
1x^2 + 1 x ^ 4 is equal to 1 this will
simplify to be x ^ 4 + 2 + 1 x ^ 4 is
equal to 1 and that means x ^ 4 + 1 x ^
4 is equal
to1 so now we've solved the problem x ^
of 100 + + 1X ^ 100 is equal to -1 and
that's the
answer for completeness I'm going to
illustrate another method to solve the
problem using complex numbers I don't
know if it's any better but it's just
good to know different ways to solve it
so we start out with this equation and
we want to evaluate Z 100 + 1/ z 100 we
can multiply both sides of the equation
by Z and then we get a quadratic
equation so we can solve this and we get
two different Roots we'll call them s
and t what we're going to do is convert
this from rectangular form into Polar
form so we want s to be equal to a plus
b i or R multiplied e to the I Theta so
we need to calculate what R and Theta
are so in this case r will be equal to
the square < TK of 3 + one all over 4
and that's equal to one and then Theta
will be equal to the arct tangent of 1/
< tk3 which is equal to piun / 6 so one
solution is equal to e to ^ of I Pi / 6
I'm just going to illustrate this for
one of the solutions you can then look
at the other root and do the same thing
convert that into Polar coordinates so
now from here it will be relatively easy
to
calculate s ^ 100 + 1 / s ^ 100 so we
substitute in what s is equal to then we
just use exponent rules so have e to 100
I pi/ 6 Plus e to^ 00 I pi/
6 now every 2 pi can be canceled out in
the angle so this simplifies to be e to
the^ of 2 I pi over 3 plus e ^ of -2 I
pi over 3 we evaluate this back into
rectangular coordinates we get1 + I tk3
all/ 2 plus-1 - I3 all two so we end up
with just the answer of -1 so that's
another way you could solve the
problem thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
[Music]
time
oh